The robot dance is the greatest novelty
dance of all time.
You can do it if you're a kid,
or an expert. And the robot’s rise is the result of style and technology playing at the same beat.
The robot goes back before the word robot was invented.
Some of the first films show people doing mannequin dances that have the same stilted motion.
With the invention of the word “robot” in 1921, it was possible to become a new type of creature
for a newly mechanical age.
As robots became part of pop culture people sought ways to interpret them. But the modern robot dance has
different parts. In the late 60s, a mime named Robert Shields (and later his partner, Lorenne Yarnell) were inspired by mannequin dances, and Shields brought his
robot onto shows like Merv Griffin’s, where he dissected them with an engineer’s precision.
But the dance wouldn’t exist today without the performers who later set it to music.
Some were inspired by Shields, and some were independent inventors. Don Campbell —the inventor of Campbellocking—
locking formed to crew that included
poppers, lockers, and robotters like
Charles “Robot” Washington and Bill “Slim the Robot” Williams (who actually had worked as a living mannequin in a clothing store).
They popped, locked, and robotted in recognizable dances.
Soul Train gave them a platform. Key pioneers  like Damita Jo Freeman robotted next to James Brown on TV.
robotted next to James Brown on TV.
Together, all these influences — Soul Train, lockers, and the occasional mime — made what we call the robot.
lockers and the occasional mind made
what we call the robot but its have
But it tool another spark another spark to make the robot mainstream that spark was the Jackson 5
The Jackson 5 performed their hit 1973 song “Dancing Machine” on Soul Train, but that was just the beginning.
There were other songs, like Rufus Thomas’s Funky Robot, but by 1974, Dancing Machine was a worldwide hit.
with world wide professional campaign.
They performed it on the Mike Douglas Show and on Carol Burnett.
They telethoned it with Jerry Lewis, showed off for Johnny Carson, and even enlisted Cher to do it with them.
The dance, assembled by street dancers, Soul Train, (and a few cutting edge mimes) took over thanks to the Jacksons.
They ensured it was forever known as a dancing machine — that is, a robot.
All those parts gave us the robot we all know today, equally enjoyed by uncoordinated five-year olds,
uncles at weddings, and practiced professionals.
And it succeeded because for a mechanical dance, the robot is surprisingly flexible.
A big thanks to all the robotters who
let us use their footage in this video.
You can see more of their dance scene in
their own YouTube channels down below in
the description. Great way to waste to
a few hours late.
In addition to getting footage, I also wanted to get some expertise. So I asked
Adrian Barambila a.k.a "El Tiro" what this move is called.
And he said that if you were pressed to find a name for he'd call it an arm isolation.
However he'd also probably it the cheesy robot dance move because it's the go-to move for
non-professionals